françois a dit mme alliot président de
l'institut de recherche asia center
bonjour jean françois di muzio merci de
répondre à nos questions sur rt france
comment est-ce qu'il faut interpréter
cette nouvelle salve de sanctions du
congrès américain contre la chine répond
probablement attendre au coin on peut se
demander si outre cette détermination
amuser comme ça et élu d'opposition en
compte et volonté d'acheter ou de
provoquer les délais ni donc la
provocation fonctionne c'est à dire que
la chine n'ont donc pas déclenché les
hostilités
claire et déterminée
djallit des états unis puisqu'elle sans
que menez nervosité du côté des litanies
une ligne rouge n'est plus très loin
dans celle qui déroule c'est quoi ça
pourrait effectivement un ralentissement
des affaires depuis d'affaires entre les
états unis et hong kong
les 2 500 dépend fondamentalement la
décision des patrons américains
en revanche là où il ya moyen de changer
la donne c'est bien sûr l'utilisation
d'internet
on sait que la devise américaine elle
est souveraine et qu'une désignant une
cour américaine peut intervenir
sanctionné l'utilisation 7/2 ont des
moyens de paiement ou dans un cadre
réglementaire n'est pas celle qui pour
inspecter ses vêtements les banques
chinoises parties qui sont visés par ce
qui est mentionné
il est venu là elle pourrait se voir
effectivement empruntés par les mêmes
sanctions
c'est râpé des bandes en particulier
passé qu'une hypothèse
ce qui est beaucoup plus sérieux en fait
c'est la réelle parce qu'ils entendent
et aux stratégies actives et a fait
notre article
vous évoquez les éventuelle riposte de
pékin met justement en termes de
déclarations pur et dur il n'y a pas
encore eu de déclarations de la part de
pékin
à quoi est-ce qu'il faut s'attendre dans
les prochaines 12 heures est ce que nos
fils yale va prendre la parole
ça fait partie et des secrets le bac est
carré crise on a toujours constaté que
le niveau des sanctions américaines y
compris lorsqu'il y avait cette seconde
guerre commerciale était supérieur au
niveau des actions qui ont aidé à lancer
ou réelle c'est proportionnel et c'est
normal puisque de toute façon la chine
exporte plus en termes purement
commerciaux vous que les états unis
exportent vers la chine donc tout est
forcément et je pense qu'il ya une
posture qui apparaît de plus en plus
c'est ainsi qu'ils fait que en même
temps que la chine est assise sur ce
qu'elle appelle son bon endroit dans
tout ce qu'ils considéraient comme son
territoire
on y compris elle veut apparaître
sinon comme le gentil en tout cas comme
le moins méchant dans l'agressivité
donc ces sanctions qui seront annoncées
elles seront probablement moins
effective moins forte et d'un niveau
moins élevé plus que washington prêtant
à ce stade
appliqué il reste à voir ensuite la
dimension de l'application n'hésite pas
à lancer par l'anssi pelosi par le sénat
et par le congrès dernière question
rapidement jean françois di muzio
washington dénonce également des
manoeuvres en mer de chine orientale
c'était une annonce dans cette nuit
pourquoi cette sortie maintenant et
surtout pourquoi cette zone est elle si
stratégique c'est c'est l'enjeu
principal
d'abord parce que d'un point de vue
économique et d'un point d'une stratégie
que cette mère crie de concluante que la
lucarne et concentre tous les flux de
matières premières qui alimentation du
nord-est
donc il ya l'importance d'un couloir
stratégique bien sûr qui est
fondamentale mais il ya aussi une
opposition fondamentale sur le droit qui
s'applique à cette région puisqu'il ya
en fait les revendications territoriales
si loin ce qui n'est pas reconnue par
les interlocuteurs de la chine est donc
le déploiement contraire aux engagements
de la chine de forces militaires aux
alentours des îles paracels le fait que
pékin déploie des manoeuvres militaires
est contraire à la foi à ses engagements
et aussi est-ce que ce soit et bien sûr
toutes les parties prenantes les états
unis qu'on peut considérer comme une
partie extérieure à la région
mais comme ça a été rappelé aussi le
vietnam le gall taiwan étant un peu
différent puisque taiwan à des
revendications identiques à la chine ou
le titre normalement d'une continuité
entre taiwan et la chine qui remonte au
début du 20e siècle
merci jean françois di mais dieu d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes le président de l'institut
asia center